parler de l'avenir des people puisqu'on
va avoir bac un voyant quelqu'un qui lit
l'avenir et puis un médium alors un
médium c'est quelqu'un qui lit dans rien
elle va nous expliquer mais pendant un
moment sachez quand même que le cnrs
s'intéresse à cette personne parce que
notamment elle peut entrer en contact
avec les morts comme dans ghost regarder
le sujet ont les ressources je suis
huissier de justice à marseille j'ai été
contacté par une équipe de production
qui réalise un programme deborah
l'expérience inédite dans laquelle
deborah bénisti médium participent à une
expérience de médiumnité ya quelqu'un
qui ne peluche dans le dos l'endroit
envoyé par qui
une peluche selah sue venir c'est
quelque chose qui date de bien longtemps
je crois que les beige et bleu ou
quelque chose comme ça c'est ça
s'étendant je ne crois pas
malheureusement qui a une vie au delà
nos six batteries dans cette affaire
c'est comment effectivement une personne
comme deborah puisse arriver
effectivement à donner ces informations
qui semblent venir de l'au delà des
choses on était extrêmement étonnante on
est surtout
perplexe en face d'un phénomène
qui
dépasse le reproductible parce que tout
le monde n'est pas comme elle
qui dépasse
le
nom
il sera presse devant leur public meghan
markle va-t-elle divorce et célyne
durand vingtaine revenir sur scène
matthieu delormeau va-t-il remplacer
cyril hanouna pas pourquoi ça fait rire
ou me saouler là et
cyril hanouna bâti d'être ministre
toutes les réponses dans un instant
grâce à claude alexis bonsoir bonsoir en
toi on a refait sa couleur est oui et en
quoi ça vous les faites vous même nom
chez qui 200 chats non loin de sange
c'était super bien un timide super bien
à jimmy de bien tu as vu mon annexes et
des beaux rackets avec comme ça ces
champions de son histoire
[Applaudissements]
non pas cagole c'est parce que je
voulais dire mais il est moi je leur ai
dit comme ça mais vous vous êtes
magnifique et vous vous êtes médium
alors déjà tous les deux donc médium en
amour médium ses contacts et les
personnes décédées d'accord quand on
aime on est très bien mais on les
appellera et vous bien sûr on vous voit
tout le temps à la télévision vous
prenez un appel vous donnez à date de
naissance et vous dites ce qui va se
passer exactement alors attention va
vous montrer les candidats aux élections
et chacun vous avez dire qui sera au
second tour --qu'il a gagné tu lui dis
alors il a manqué le président alors
voilà qui sera au second tour claude
alexis
ben ali près creissan et mc ren macro et
pécresse madame deborah alors je crois
que yvert forum je vous explique que ça
marche pas comme ça avec moi il faut que
j'appelle quelqu'un qui parle à travers
moi vous
vous appelez il faut appeler quelqu'un
qui s'appelleront est ce qu'il faut
appeler quelqu'un qui s'appelle
ronaldinho avec son téléphone c'est
madame qui l'appelle l'intrus 5 j'ai
intégré
on est à présent ils arrivent dans le
numéro alors qu on se tait si vous
voulez passer mes amitiés à ben il va
vous parler à mon avis c'est vrai alors
j'ai un guide qui s'appelle rojo il
passe à travers ma voix on y croit on
n'y croit pas en attendant parfois il
peut y avoir des preuves parfois ça peut
être rigolo parfois somme ça a pas grand
chose mais je vais vous montrer je donne
le public de ce taire bien sûr je vais
appeler rohaut qui va nous parler un
petit peu qu'est ce que je veux dire les
ont formés je vais vous dire enchanté je
suis ravi d'être là ce soir je suis ravi
d'être avec un monsieur de leurs mots
qui a préparé son émission mais qui a
déjà tout oublié on a déjà oublié la
moitié en tout cas une chose est sûre
c'est pour les élections je peux vous
dire juste une chose c'est que il va y
avoir un très grand retournement être
grosse surprise un petit peu la fin de
l'élection vous verrez je peux pas vous
en dire plus aujourd'hui ce tri
c'est à tailler
ses jets pas d'accord
montant le dessin je vois lorsque vous
m'avez dit c'est que ronnie a dit je
peux rien dire meilleur une surprise en
gros oui embrouille qui s'en fichent
c'était pas ça qui m'intéresse pas je
suis déjà alors j'essaie
d'être un bateau qui n'osent pas
mitterrand alors attention alors meghan
markle va-t-il bratel divorcer c'est la
grande tendance en ce moment on en parle
beaucoup claude je ne ressens pas de
divorce pour eux pendant en tout cas pas
maintenant mais c'est un couple qui
n'ira pas dans la durée ah c'est vrai
c'est intéressant d'un couple dans le
dans le temps ce jeudi entre 5 et 7 ans
harry retournera d'occupation en
angleterre oui et il retrouve rentrée
cas c'est étrange mais ce sera sa
dernière épouse assez intéressant sur
claude souvent il y des choses très
justes par auront aussi
on va repartir de côté kroes
le sujet va intéresser cette fois ci
c'est vraiment désolé d'emmerdés
oméga de markale va-t-elle divorcé cette
séquence est assez éloigné les enfants
du primaire c'est bien je dirais pas
tout de suite le ballon un petit peu de
temps la même temps la motion faf la
violence et je fasse toujours après je
vais passer pour un imbécile
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la régie pour monsieur la région mathieu
de vous et promets que je vais très bien
on est sur une caméra cachée par
c'est une vraie séquence
ok c'est aux caisses aux savants c'est
une amie de sa note alors on va
commencer par rojo puisque s'attendait
alors céline dion ou batave céline dion
va t'elle remonter sur scène
en 2022 claude pardon mais cette fois-ci
0 on a beau dire on ne donne pas de date
mans va lui demander c'est moi ça me
fait chi rose
donne pas de date et de ne pas
d'élection il donne rien il se prononce
sur rien tu vois
je sais pas réellement pourquoi vous
m'avez invité
[Musique]
compris alors ok ce qu'il en dit on
encore une belle séquence qu'elle était
la question oui et partie de ces 40 ou
remonter sur scène et bien me dire
également remonté un peu fatigué mais un
petit peu et va vous étonner mais
vraiment vous détenez oui elle remontera
sur scène
non on est en train de dire que le cnrs
il serait hors et autres infos sur 20
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
j'ai une faculté quand même un peu plus
sérieusement
c'est nous avons baissé d'intensité mais
reste quand la guitare ces mots sont
la question était peut-être compliqué
trop directement on se dit c'est
peut-être moi qui ai pas compris la cnps
on n'est pas tout ces japonnais de plus
simple
alors que le délai c'est déjà céline
dion va remonter sur sa nouba même pas
là qui
abuse niche
el had montera sur scène mais paf sur
2022 non je ressemble plus d'émission se
prendre pour elle sur la fin de l'année
war tout début 2003 d'accord est par
contre je parle pas santé parce que
c'est pas vrai chacun son métier mais il
faut qu'elle reste vigilante au niveau
déplacement
entre qu'elle bouge car est bien que ça
m'a pas trop quelle boule
euros je peux le faire chier
alors attention alors on concentre toi
s'il te plait je sais que rennes
t'intéresser que voilà
matthieu delormeau va-t-il remplacer
cyril hanouna qui devient à fatiguer sur
ces 8 et bat il devenir une grande star
est-ce que matthieu delormeau et une
grande star je dirais qu'il est déjà le
dirait qu'ils adorent ça ils adorent
qu'on l'adulé l'adorent quand même
énorme pour l'instant je te vois pas le
remplacer mais pour l'instant je
m'entends émission elle va encore
changer mon grand j'en suis désolé
[Applaudissements]
où qu'ils soient je t'emmerde rompt avec
un gant
non seulement j'ai pas remplacer cyril
mais l'émission va encore changer en
mieux
argent servant tu peux des scieries les
l'accusé avait brillé au mieux bon là
claude moisy matthieu delormeau va-t-il
remplacer cyril hanouna sur s'est vite
parce que celle de la très fatigué non
par contre il n en continue et j'aime
j'aime arriver parce que ça fait dix ans
que j'annonce enfin pas de 10 ans mais
c'est 5 6 ans que j'annonce que cyril
hanouna sera pas pas l'avoir maintien
sera pas pas être
maire
[Applaudissements]
m
le matelas alors au niveau de hauts
niveaux de tpm paix à l'émission
continuera mais
il sera remplacé par un autre animateur
à mesa soir ce sera un souhait en tout
les cas de sa part pour la simple raison
c'est que cyril hanouna occupera
d'autres fonctions la force tranquille
remplacement comment passer un peu de là
où on ne l'attend pas et c'est quelqu'un
qui deviendront plus qu'un président
d'une chaîne series irin président d'une
chaîne donc du coup il va s'en aller
parce qu'ils le méritent et au repos
bien mérité ce prix donné tu as tout
donné tu es le de gaulle tu as sauvé la
france a trouvé la chaîne émanant fou tu
te reposer je serai là pour toi et du
coup t'as pas répondu qu'il remplace
skoun
non non
non non non il ya d'autres choses pour
ta qui arrivent beaucoup payent à cette
émission que tu vas continuer à meilhan
également une reprise d'une émission qui
sera une télé réalité
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'aimerais poser une question j'ai à
néant par un médium qui sont qui sont
parlées nous et je vais rappeler la plus
grande collaboration entre la presse
people et les médiums c'était en 2010
c'est qu'avant de travail à closer je
passais par voici et j'étais à france
dimanche et à l'époque le directeur de
la rédaction a souhaité interviewer
claude françois depuis l'au delà oui et
ça s'est fait très sérieusement il ya
une vraie double page avec une interview
complète de claude françois qui nous
expliquait qui donnait des concerts là
haut avec les anges et c'est qu'il avait
même vu le film podium depuis ces petits
nuages donc est ce que vous y croyez est
ce que c'est possible qu'une interview
comme ça et soirée elle tout simplement
alors je veux bien croire qu'il y ait qu
il y ait quelque chose après la prenne à
lui mais après rentrer dans ce genre de
délire très honnêtement j'ai pas du tout
c'est comme j'avais une wayang si vous
voulez qu'ils avaient dit sur le plateau
de sur un plateau de télévision pourquoi
par rapport à m pokora qu'avait reprise
si vous voulez les nénuphars françois
n'était pas content parce qu'ils les
interpréterait pas pouvoir si on montre
comment elle l'est comme ils le
souhaitaient et j'ai trouvé ça un peu un
peu dire que je veux non parce que
chacun désert près de la surface on
voyait qu'il y est mais ouais après la
mort oui là c'est sûr d'accord est juste
un petit mot quand même ro ro ro et moi
non comment
moi j'aimerais bien dire ce que j'en
pense j'en pense non mais pas de ça
parce que ça ou claude françois il est
mort on essaie de viser les jeunes sur
la sig que françois cela monsieur
charmant dormir un peu est ce que vous
pensez pas la laddh pardon de
s'intéresser un petit peu à moi
l'avenir l'avenir ici là sur la chaîne
c'est cyril hanouna ce qui va être
ministre ça c'est ma question que dire
euros est-ce que cyril va être ministre
ou autres ministres c'est ce que j'ai
demandé lui aussi
est ce que
ton ministre la ministre de la chaîne il
m'a toujours de diriger mon bon et j'en
suis désolé mais je sais qu'il a une
bonne surprise pour toi tu en peu de
temps et tu vas très content tu verras
mais ce qui va être ministre
non il sera pas ministre bon